All right, let's get started.
So, last time Tatsu talked about scaling
laws, and we're going to take a little
bit break from that
um and talk about an inference.
Um so, the problem of inference is very
simple.
You've trained a model,
and you're given a prompt, and you want
to produce the response, usually as
accurately and as quickly as you can.
So, inference turns out to be
um only one lecture, but it's actually
of growing importance.
And it shows up in
many places.
So, clearly once you've trained a model,
you don't just sit there and um if
you're a researcher, you put a plot in
your paper of here's how my model works,
but um for everyone else, you actually
want to use this model. So, what does
use look like? It could be chatting with
an AI assistant or chatbot. It could be
doing code completion. Um these days,
agents are very popular, and uh that
requires inference. Um batch data
processing as well.
Um
it's also used for for evaluation, um
for evaluation that requires generation
in particular.
And it's also used inside training. If
you're doing reinforcement learning, you
need to have a model, you generate
rollouts, and you score them, and you
update the weights appropriately.
So, inference shows up all over the uh
place.
And you know, efficiency
as the is the you know, theme of this
class, really matters more than ever
here.
And even if you just look at uh the
actual use um
kind of uh app uh vantage point,
you know, training is a one-time cost.
It could be very expensive. It is very
expensive, but once you're done with
that, that's it. But, inference is a
repeated cost. You You kind of incur
them every single day. Um so, you know,
OpenAI is estimated to produce 8.6
trillion tokens a day.
Um and just for reference, GPT-4,
which came out earlier this year, was
trained on 32 trillion tokens.
So, in less than 4 days, the number of
tokens that OpenAI has to produce, and
therefore the compute is
um you know, at least the GPT-4.
And of course, you know, even the
frontier models might be trained on more
tokens, but still inference um the
number of tokens generated is is going
to be higher.
So, that's just a you know, some
perspective.
And moreover, I think this the
importance of inference has grown in the
last year because
you know, once upon a time, we thought
of language models as primarily as
chatbots or assistants, where you put in
a prompt, you get back a response, and
presumably the goal of the human is to
read the response. But now as we move
more into a agentic world,
what it looks like is that a query goes
in, and the agent is going to do a bunch
of stuff. It's going to think, it's
going to reason, it's going to call some
tools, it's going to introspect, and at
the end of the day, it will produce some
output for a human to read.
So, the most of the tokens that the
agent produces is actually not for uh
reading.
And so, you should really think about
the number of tokens generated as really
the compute spent. And there's no sort
of limit. If you have an ambitious
enough problem, you're going to need
much uh much compute and a lot of
tokens.
Right? So, if you were in the chatbot
world, maybe inference um you after a
certain point, it's fast enough because
humans can only read uh so fast. But for
agent, you know, there's no kind of
limit to how much value you can get out
of squeezing more out of inference.
So, there's a lot of people are doing
inference um on the commercial side.
Um of course, all the the closed API
providers have to serve their models, so
inference is a big deal for them.
And there is also a bunch of providers
serving open weight models um and
providing inference um as well. And in
the open source community, there's a
bunch of packages. Uh so, v l m is
probably a popular one, kind of a a a
go-to.
Um s g lang
is another one that's uh particularly
good for agentic workloads, but maybe
not as popular um yet. And then there's
tensor r t from Nvidia, which is really,
you know, fast, but it's more uh narrow.
Um and then llama c p p, if you want to
run inference on your
um
on c p u, um this is a popular, you
know, package.
Okay. So, hopefully I've argued that
inference is is huge.
Um if you can make inference, you know,
twice as fast or even 10% faster, that
is a big deal.
So, now the question is what is fast
mean?
So, there's a few metrics that capture
the notion of fast, and they're going to
be applicable and in different settings
and have different trade-offs.
So, one metric of fast is time to first
token or t t f t.
This is essentially how long a user
waits before any generation happens. So,
you put in a query into
uh chat g p t, and
uh some number of, you know,
milliseconds um
um passes by, and then
and then from the point the first token
comes in, that is that is the time. And
this is generally useful for interactive
applications because
um that latency where you're just
waiting and doing nothing is is the
longer that is, the worse the user
experience. And as soon as tokens come
in, it doesn't maybe have to be that
fast because if you're going to read it
anyway,
um you can't read that fast.
So, the second metric is latency.
Um and this is from the standpoint of an
individual user, how fast are tokens
appearing for one query? This is also
important for interactive, you know,
applications.
Um so, basically, this is how fast the
tokens are kind of streaming through.
And then the second related concept is
is throughput, measuring tokens per
second.
This is how fast tokens are appearing
for many queries.
So, latency or one over latency and
throughput are clearly very related.
Right? It's it's very kind of a line of
the you know, in general, many
interventions will make latency and
throughput, you know, better.
But,
uh as we'll see later, there is actually
a trade-off here.
And throughput is useful for if you're
doing a bunch of batch processing.
Right? You just want you have, you know,
a petabyte of data and you want to
process it with a language model. Um you
just want that job to get done. It
doesn't matter if one uh query is coming
in faster, sooner, or later.
Okay.
So, what determines the efficiency by
either any of these metrics
of of inference?
Um so, the the high-level bit is as
follows.
And this is kind of the
you know, maybe one high-level bit to
remember from the lecture is that um
when you're doing training,
you see all the tokens at once because
in supervised fine-tuning, you see all
the tokens,
and you can parallelize over the
sequence. Remember, think about in the
Transformer, the calculation for
attention MLP, um the sequence is just a
dimension, so So a big tensor that gets
multiplied.
Um and so you essentially process all
the tokens at once.
In inference, you can't do that.
You have to generate, because of the
auto regressive nature of inference,
tokens sequentially, one at a time.
So this is the fundamental problem
of why inference is a very different
workload than training, because you
can't parallelize across the sequence
dimension.
And therefore, as we'll see later, it's
going to be harder to have high
arithmetic intensity or fully utilize
the compute.
Okay.
All right. So let's let's go on. So
first, I'm going to just say maybe with
a preview of what's in this lecture.
First, I'm going to do some math to
understand
the arithmetic intensity and throughput
and latency, how to think about that for
a transformer.
And then I'm going to talk about various
techniques to reduce the
the cost by you know, making the KV
cache smaller, quantizing model pruning,
and then finally I'll talk about
speculative decoding and then some kind
of practical concerns.
All right. So
this is going to be a bit of a review,
mostly kind of swapping in and make sure
we're on the same page with respect to
notation.
Much of this lecture is based on the
scaling book from Google on
you know, transformers and inference. So
I do recommend that people go check it
out. It's very nicely written and some
of the picture
the figures are
you know, generously
lifted from that book.
Okay. So
just to establish a bit of notation to
understand this this diagram.
So we're going to use symbols
think about in I knobs to denote
dimensions, but also their kind of
length. So, B is going to be the the
batch dimension and also the number of
sequences. T is going to be the sequence
dimension, which is also the number of
tokens. D is the model dimension. H is
the head dimension.
Okay, so if I'm going to write this, um
this is taking a product between a
tensor with dimensions B, T, and D
um and another matrix of D and H and I
produce B, T, H. So, what is going on
here is that there are some dimensions
marked red, which are going to be
contracting.
These dimensions appear in both operands
and disappear from the the results.
And then there's going to be other
regular dimensions in black that appear
only
in one operand and stay in the result.
Okay, so this is kind of the general
form.
Another case is if you have blue
dimensions, that means they're they're
batching dimensions and they appear in
both but stay in the result. They do not
get
contracted or reduced.
Okay, so the interpretation here as
we'll see later is that we have this
tensor for every
sequence and token position, you have a
vector and you want to multiply that by
a you know, a matrix.
Um and then here you're basically taking
a bunch of dot products between two you
know, tensors.
Okay, so with that in mind, this in all
its full glory is the description of
a transformer block.
Um so it looks a little bit like a
circuit diagram. There's a lot of
details here, but I actually find this
probably the most
kind of crisp definition of what a
transformer is.
You know, you see a lot of description
of transformer and frankly a lot of them
are kind of you know, it's hard to
understand what is exactly happening.
This one basically tells you exactly the
shapes of the tensors and allows you to
reason about the the the dependency. So,
um for a transformer block, you take the
X, um which is the activations of one
layer, you feed it through attention,
and then you feed it through MLP.
Um and and just as a kind of a quick
refresher,
um the
the X and you um project it using a
query matrix, um a key matrix, and a
value matrix. Um you'll see here that
um we have um
N, which is the number of heads, and H
is the dimension of each head. So, the
query matrix is um batch times sequence
times number of heads times the head
dimension. Um and K and V, instead of
having N, we have K, which we'll see
later, um which we have a potentially
smaller number of um key value heads.
Um and then this is the attention
operation,
um where notice that there's batching
dimensions. Um so, B appears in in both,
and we're contracting over the head um
you know, dimension.
And we'll come back to why this B being
both makes inference hard, um why
attention is kind of a bottleneck there.
Okay, so just kind of hold on to that
thought.
Um
and the MLP is is kind of very, you
know, simple and straightforward. Um you
just do some, you know, mat mals. This
is the um
the the gating um
um you know, matrix. This is the up
projection and the down projection. So,
um I think you guys have implemented
this, so I don't want to belabor it, but
just to swap in the notation.
Um by convention, we're going to assume
that um
in the MLP, um
the MLP up projects the D-dimensional uh
model dimension into four times that, so
F is always, you know, think about it as
4D whenever you see F. Um and then the
model dimension gets split across the N
heads. So, um the model dimension is
always equal to number of heads times
the head dimension. Um
and then the
uh the number of uh heads gets split in
the case of uh group query attention
into the number of groups and the number
of heads uh per uh group.
Um and finally, we have two variables S
and T, which both represents the um kind
of the sequence dimension. And the
difference is that S is going to be uh
represent the number of um input tokens
to per and T is going to represent the
number of output tokens. So, in training
time, these two are the same because
we're predicting all the um the same um
inputs as outputs. Um at inference time,
uh T is going to be one and S is going
to be the input.
Okay. So, another review for arithmetic
intensity. So, I talked about this in
the second lecture. So, just as a
warm-up, suppose I'm multiplying two
matrices, a B by D matrix and a D by F
matrix. So, intuition, B is the batch
dimension, D is a hidden dimension or
the model dimension, and F is the up
projection dimension in NLP.
Um so, remember what is the arithmetic
intensity?
I have to count flops and I have to
count um the amount of memory moved.
Okay. So, we can we can do this as
follows. So,
um what do you have to do to multiply
these matrices?
Um now, remember the systems, you know,
lectures,
um you have to read X from um HBM.
And if you're storing everything on
BF16, which is the case for for
inference,
um we're going to have a 2 * B * D.
You're going to read W. That's going to
to be another 2 * D * F. Um you're going
to do the matmul, so that's um
number of flops is 2 * B * D * F.
And
um
and then you're going to write it back.
Okay? So, every time you read and write,
it's basically the basically number of
entries. It's a kind of a quadratic-like
term. And matmuls are are cubic. And
remember, um this is going to be
important because that's how you're
going to get high arithmetic intensity.
So, number of total number of flops is
um
you know, the the cubic and then um the
bytes transferred is the sum of the
reads and writes.
Okay. So, remember arithmetic intensity
is how much compute we do per byte
transfer. And we want this to be high.
So, the intensity is is going to be
equal to
um
you know, flops over bytes transfer. And
I'm representing all these things
symbolically because it'll be uh easier
to to see and work with rather than
numbers.
Um one kind of just
you know, simplification we can make is
that suppose that the batch dimension
here is much less than D and F.
Then we can simplify this.
So, um in particular, what this is doing
is saying D equals C * B and F equals C
* B and let C goes to infinity, so both
D and F are really large and B is
smaller. And this just reduces to the
intensity of B.
Okay. So, the upshot of that is that um
remember when we did arithmetic
intensity for um um you know, matmul,
it's was something like N over uh N over
uh three.
Um and this is the kind of the analog
where instead of just having
you know, one a variable for dimension
having square matrices, we have
non-square matrices.
Okay. So, just to compare, so with the
accelerator intensity of uh
um hardware is
you look at the flops per second in in
the in the spec sheet. You look at how
much memory bandwidth, how fast memory
gets moved between HPM. You divide and
that is the accelerator intensity.
And now you compare your computational
uh computations intensity with your
accelerator intensity. And if it's
greater,
then you're compute bound, which is
good. If you're less, then you're memory
bound and that's bad. So in this case,
uh for H100 for this particular mammal
operation, you're compute bound if um
the batch size is greater than 295.
So here's an extreme case. So suppose
you just have one example.
Okay?
Um
what happens you have one example, then
your arithmetic intensity is going to be
one.
And
this is going to be memory bound.
Um and you can kind of see what's going
on here. You're reading this DF matrix,
um but B is only one, so you're
effectively doing only two times D times
F uh flops.
Um so, you know, that's And this is
basically kind of the workload that
you'll see in inference. You don't get
these like full matrices, you get these
like very thin um
matrices or tensors.
Okay, let me stop there in case there's
any questions.
Yeah.
>> Uh in the transpose slide,
I just wanted to confirm
I'm going to say it into the mic.
Um
uh
the transpose
Is that the transpose
Can I search transpose across
across across uh UBI I think it's across
the board.
>> [clears throat]
>> Yeah. Should that be across
tables instead of heads?
>> I'm having trouble with the connection.
>> [snorts]
>> Um, let's see. So, the number of
groups here
is
uh
Wait, I'm just making sure. So, K is the
number of key value heads.
And um
so, you have
Q
Sorry, G Sorry, G per KV head.
Um
so
>> my mistake. You treat
>> Uh
each key
head will have a few queries.
Uh
>> Yeah.
>> Of course, that's why
you only have
>> Um
>> But, when you compute attention
and that means G is the number of query
heads per key.
That means we have two tables.
That's my point.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, um I think Yeah, I think
you're right. So, K should be the number
of uh groups and G should be the number
of uh the you know, heads per one of
those groups.
Yeah. Okay. Thanks for that. I'll fix
that later.
Okay.
Um so, let's talk a little bit more
about the arithmetic intensity of
inference. Okay. So, um here's how
uh to think about what's happening in
inference. Let's say you do student
naively.
So, here is um a prompt, "Never going to
give you." I'm going to the transformer.
Um and the transformer is uh does, you
know, generates keys and values and
activations. And at the end of the day,
it generates uh logits over the output
vocabulary.
And you sample a token.
And that token um gets concatenated with
um the prompt and then you just do this
again. You generate never, you attach
that to the prompt and so on and so
forth.
Okay, so this is the most naive thing.
If you have a black box that takes a
sequence and outputs a distribution of a
tokens, which is exactly what a
transformer does, you can just apply
this repeatedly.
Okay, so this is works, but this is
really bad because each time you
generate one token um you actually take
order T squared time where T is the
number of, you know, tokens that you've
generated so far. So generating T tokens
is actually T
cubed.
Okay?
Because the the attention is already T
squared and you have to do that you
know, one for every once for every
token.
So this is
you know, pretty bad.
But the observation is that you don't
actually have to do this.
Um a lot of the work can actually be
shared across prefixes. So for example,
if you're over generating never versus
you're generating up, you're actually
computing a lot of the same key values
for
you know,
never going to give. So these tokens,
they shouldn't change.
Okay?
And this is because it's a causal, you
know, transformer. If it was
bidirectional, then if you attach a
token, then everything changes.
But if it's causal, then the activations
here don't change based on any tokens
you append.
So with that observation, the first
obvious thing is to store a KV cache in
HBM
so that between successive token
generations, you can just reuse the KV
cache.
So that means when you are trying to
you know, generate going to, you don't
actually have to compute all the keys
and activations of these previous um
previous
uh tokens. So, this is what it looks
like with a KV cache. Okay, so
um there's going to be two stages,
prefill. So, you get the prompt and you
populate the KV cache, which is the set
of key and value pairs that the
transformer computes.
Um and then you generate the logic, just
the same computations we did before.
And now um
now you have the KV cache here um and
then this distribution, which you sample
at a token.
And now you feed that through the
transformer, which you know
uses this cache
um and then produces a
both uh the distribution of the next
tokens, but a new KV, which is the the
basically activations corresponding to
the token up.
And then this gets fed in.
So, now you have the uh command the KV
cache, you have these um logics you
sample and then that feeds through the
transformer, you output the distribution
of the next tokens as well as the the
next um
the new token, which you add to the KV
cache and so on and so forth.
Okay, so the KV cache formally is for
every
you know sequence, so there's B of them,
for every token
um there's S of them and for um
every layer and every head, you store H
dimensional vector.
Okay, and just to reiterate for
inference, there's prefill, you're given
a prompt, you encode
um the prompt into
these uh you know vectors and this is
parallelizable just like in training
because you see the entire prompt, you
can compute the
um the KV cache and then in generation,
you generate the new response tokens,
you know, sequentially. But, at least
you don't have to pay for um generating
the KV cache of the tokens that you
already looked at.
Okay. So, is everyone comfortable with
the KV cache? Any questions about this?
All right. So, let's try to figure out
um the flops and memory IO for both the
MLP and attention layers.
Um so, remember, S is the number of
tokens we're kind of conditioning on.
And T is the number of tokens we're
generating.
Um so, we're going to do this sort of
abstractly, and then later we'll specify
to the prefill where T equals S and
generation T equals 1.
So, for the MLP layers, and through all
of this, I'm just going to look at the
matmuls because the the matmuls are the
thing that actually uh require a lot of
work. Everything else can be
um is not that many flops, um and can be
potentially fused into the matmul, too.
Um okay. So, let's do this uh
calculation. So, this is the same as the
matrix uh calculations. I'm not going to
maybe belabor step through every single
detail here, but just the form is you
read X from um
high bandwidth memory.
Um you read all the parameters.
You you compute the
um upward projection.
Um and then, you know, you write it to
HPM. You compute the
the um
the gate, um
and you write it HPM, and then you uh
compute
the basically the down projection of
that, and you write it um to HBM.
Okay, so the number of flops is uh, you
know, depends on P, B, and T, and D and
F. So, batch size, sequence length, um,
model dimension, and the feed forward
dimension.
Uh, MLP dimension. And the bytes
transferred is
um, you know, this expression.
Okay, so now you can compute the
arithmetic intensity, which again is
flops divided by bytes, you know,
transferred. Um, so this is some
expression.
Um, we're going to assume that just like
before, B * T is much smaller than D and
D and F. Um, and with that, then we see
that intensity is um, you know, B * T.
Okay, so this is analogous to just the
matmul case. There's more matrices and
there's like more dimensions, but
fundamentally it's kind of the same
thing. And that makes sense. An MLP is
basically a big matmul.
Okay, and it also makes sense because
the the batch dimension and the sequence
the length dimension are sort of
everything is independent. All right, in
for the MLP.
Um, they don't interact. Attention's
different story.
And so, you know, B * T. So, as long as
you have
um,
you know, in the prefill,
if you make B * T large enough, large
batches, long sequences, you'll be fine.
Now, let's look at generation. So,
remember generation,
um, there's two problems here. One is
that
the generation T equals 1.
Okay, you're only generating one
um, token at a time.
And uh, so that means your arithmetic
intensity is going to be B.
But B,
what it in generation is the number of
concurrent requests.
And so, if you're in a sort of batch
setting, you kind of can control that.
But if you're so, let's say, serving a
chatbot, it's the number of concurrent
requests is essentially, um you know,
how many users, concurrent users there
are, which can be high, can be low, so
it's a bit unpredictable, it can be
changing over time. So, that's something
we're going to address when we talk
about, um
um you know, continuous batching.
But, overall, this is not bad, right?
Because, as long as there you have large
batches,
um the sequence length isn't going to
really help you, but you have large
batches, you should be good.
So, now let's look at the attention
layer.
Um so, again, S is in the previous
tokens already generated, T is the
number of tokens you want to generate
logits for.
Um so, in attention,
you read, um
the
the QKV,
uh
you know, matrices from HPM.
Um you compute the attention.
Um you, you know, compute the softmax,
which doesn't really matter, um
and uh compute the the value, you know,
matrix. And then, you write the result
to HPM.
Okay, so the flops is B * S * T * D, and
the bytes transferred is uh this
expression.
So, this should, you know, all the
the everything is a matmul, right? So,
this is should be, um
always, you know, one degree higher of a
polynomial than, um the bytes
transferred, because it's a matmul.
The only question is, you know, what
does that factor look like?
So, that factor for attention is S * T
over S + T.
Okay?
So,
so, let's look at the prefill.
So, prefill,
um
what this is saying is that the prefill
intensity is,
um is S over 2, when T equals S.
So, this is good, right? Because as long
as you have long sequence lengths,
for attention, you're going to maintain
high arithmetic intensity.
Um notice that the batching dimension
doesn't um happen here. I'll explain a
bit, you know, why
um later.
But for generation,
this is bad news.
Right? So, the the the generated nation
intensity is S over S plus one, and
that's less than one.
Or even let's just call it one.
And arithmetic intensity, remember one
is bad. We want it to be something like
295 for each 100 to be to saturate the
compute.
And so,
you know, this is really the bottom
neck. So, we did all this analysis
um for, you know, MLP attention,
um
you know, prefill generation, and we
found this to be a bottom neck.
So, let's try to contemplate why uh this
is a bottom neck.
Um
So, unlike MLPs, so MLPs for generation
was actually okay as long as your
sequences um
I'm sorry, as your um
uh you know, batches are large enough.
So, the problem with um
this uh MLP
you know, attention is that you know,
let's look at MLPs.
Every sequence
hits the same MLP weights.
Okay? So, these don't depend on B.
Um whereas in attention layer, each
sequence has its own KV cache.
So, these all depend on, you know, B.
Um
and so, you can think about this as
um
what's the going on here is that, you
know, in the MLP case,
having B being
big actually is is helpful because you
kind of get to load these MLP weights,
you know, kind of once. Um and you can
kind of use it for all your sequences.
Right? That's how you get higher
arithmetic intensity because you use a
simplify a bit, you load it once, you do
all your batch processing, and then that
that is that is good. Whereas in
attention, you can't you know, all these
depend on B. So, increasing B doesn't
help. It's like every uh for every
sequence
you're basically doing uh a matmul.
So, they're all independent, so you
know, doing more
uh matmuls isn't uh helpful.
Just like you remember in the very
beginning,
um I showed you this example.
This also has pretty bad
uh arithmetic intensity. It's not a not
a matmul because we're essentially
batching uh by um a coordinate. And this
is essentially basically the same as
doing a dot product, which has horrible
um
uh arithmetic intensity. And remember,
this is in the attention, this B blue B
is like the cause of why um the
attention is uh
arithmetic intensity doesn't scale with
B, and why that is a bottleneck.
Okay, to just summarize here. So,
prefill is compute-bound, generation is
memory memory-bound.
So, if you look at the MLP intensity for
the
um for prefill, it's B * S, great.
Prefill for um
um for attention
intensity S over 2, not as good, but
workable. Um generation MLP intensity
also workable, requires long concurrent
requests, but it is really the
generation intense attention intensity,
which is a fundamental uh bottleneck,
and you just that's it. You you just
have to If you're sticking with a
transformer, you can't uh really, you
know, improve this.
Okay.
Uh pause there for questions.
So, now whenever you hear people say,
"Oh, inference is memory bound," um you
know why.
Okay. So, let's now use these um
intuitions and calculations to think
about our um
you know, inference metrics, throughput,
and latency, and also TTFT.
All right. So, inference is memory
bound.
Um
the the Now, the main I mean, in some
ways this simplifies a lot of things,
because when we think about how long
things take, you just look at how much
memory needs to be transferred.
Okay? Because uh assuming you
overlap uh communication and
computation, the bottleneck is going to
be just the amount of memory that you
have to deal with. Okay? So, in some
ways it's nice because it's simpler, but
in other ways it's um
frustrating that your accelerators are
sitting there not doing anything.
Um
Okay. So, let's uh walk through an
example. So, for Llama 2 13B,
um on a H100. So, what is the latency
and the throughput?
Okay. So, remember uh Llama 13B um has a
particular shape, so oops, um this is a
sequence length, the model dimension,
feedforward dimension, number of query,
number of key value heads. There's no
GQA here, so the n n equals k, head
dimension, number of layers, uh vocab
size, um and the memory bandwidth for
H100.
Okay. So,
um
So, now using this
uh this config, let's compute the the
transformer performance um you know,
statistics. Okay, so these are
our inputs here.
Um
And uh just what the statistics I'm
going to compute are going to be
um
number of parameters,
um the memory usage latency, and
throughput.
Okay. So,
first of all,
um
you know, what's cost what uh does takes
memory. So, the parameters take memory.
So, we compute the number of of
parameters.
Um
And so, you have look at the
the embeddings, the um the you know, the
MLP layers, the um the the projections
of the KQV.
Um at the end of the day, you get
um some number of parameters.
Um assuming that
uh
you know, we're doing a BF16, which
always the case for inference, then
parameters take up this many bytes.
Also, in memory is the KV cache.
Um and the KV cache is
uh the number of tokens in your sequence
times
um the number of
um your heads, and uh
KV heads um times the head dimension
times the number of layers, you have one
for the key and one for the value, and
then you have two multiple two for BF16.
Okay, so that's the size of the KV
cache.
And the total memory usage is uh
This is for each sequence you have B
sequences so that's B times that plus
the parameter size and that's the amount
of memory you you need.
And now
what's the latency? The latency is
determined by
the memory
IO.
Okay,
because inferences memory bound
most assuming you overlap communication
compute
all the memory is it's it's going to be
on
you know shuffling parameters
you know back and forth
between HPM and SRAM.
So
that's how long it takes to you know
move memory around
throughput is the inverse of latency but
we're generally B tokens in parallel so
this is
um you know this is tokens per second
this is seconds per token this is tokens
per second
as well as having an additional B
because you're processing a batch of B.
Okay, so now let's um
compute for this config what are these
actual values?
Okay, so num parameters
is
you know 13 billion so good sanity check
that is a advertised as a 13 billion
parameter model memory
is
this this term which is about 838
I guess million times B so it's
basically
you know a linear function of B
plus some other term so this is a KV
cache which grows as B this is the the
parameters which is double the number of
params.
Now latency is just this scaled by the
memory bandwidth so it has the same form
as as the memory.
And throughput is B over that.
Okay?
So, notice that latency as you increase
B, grows
um because the KV cache grows and in
order to process stuff, you have to copy
the KV cache back and forth.
And now uh throughput is more
interesting because as you increase B,
you know, throughput does improve um but
up to a limit.
Right? Because throughputting um
improves because now you're amortizing
the cost over a larger batch. Um but
also, you know, the speed at which
you're processing this obviously is also
um increasing over over time.
So, um this sort of asymptotes. It's not
going to, you know, throughput can't
possibly go to infinity.
Okay.
Any questions about uh this so far?
So, basically, you just have to remember
latency is a linear function in B. This
is the where the constant is the size of
KV cache and then this is the number of
parameters and then throughput is um
you know, some
B proportional to B over B plus
something.
Okay, so now let's instantiate this for
a bunch of situations. Okay, so if you
have batch size one,
um so this is what you would get. Uh you
get a latency of
0.0 is
0.008
um
you know, seconds per per token.
Um and the throughput is 124 tokens per
second.
So, if you what happens is you increase
the batch size,
you'll see that um
the latency goes up
um but the throughput also goes up. So,
latency gets worse, but the throughput
improves.
So, this is kind of an interesting thing
because we think about oh, we just want
to make it go fast, but fast actually
has two meanings here, which actually
depending on which one you care about
is, you know, completely opposite. If
you want to tune your batch size,
um that's going to really determine um
you if you want latency or uh
throughput.
And what happens if you increase the
let's say increase when uh we really
want high throughput because we're
processing lots of documents, let's
increase the batch size even more.
Okay, so the latency gets even worse.
Not not I mean, yeah, it gets worse.
Throughput gets even better.
But the main problem here is that your
uh memory you run out of memory.
Okay, because the memory
uh for storing this KV cache is it's
going to exceed your H100 memory.
And if you have B200s, you can increase
the batch size more, but eventually you
hit some sort of limit.
So, there's kind of limitations to how
much you can improve your throughput.
You'll never get to sort of the
asymptote um
because you'll hit uh the memory.
Okay. And also, your your throughput,
you know, is getting your gain you're
kind of diminishing as well.
So, increasing batch size worsens the
latency
because now you have a larger KV cache
to read and write.
Um and remember, it's batched, so if
you're individual query, you have to
wait for everyone to finish. So, you
have to basically you get it you're not
waiting for a bus, and the latency's,
you know, pretty high. You wait, and
then but uh and then you go. Whereas,
the throughput of a bus is pretty good
because you can move everyone at at
once.
Um
so uh the the throughput improves as
batch size increases because remember,
the parameters uh are are shared, and
you load that, you know, once
into into memory and you can process a
lot of sequences.
Okay, so trade-off between latency and
throughput. Just to make sure everyone's
aligned, smaller batch sizes uses better
latency but worse throughput. Large
batch sizes yield better throughput but
worse latency.
Okay.
I'm not going to really talk about
parallelism too much. There's also
another dimension of inference, which is
you can, you know, shard your your model
across multiple,
devices. You can look at the scaling
book chapter on inference if you want to
know more.
Just as a kind of a very trivial
example, if you launch five M copies of
the model, the latency is the same then
the throughput increases by by M.
Um
And then, the other metric we didn't
talk about is time to first token. And
this is essentially the time it takes to
do prefill.
Because after you finish prefill, then
you can basically start generating.
Okay.
So, if you want
uh you know
to fast to if you want
So, if
you know, faster TTFT, you should use
smaller batch sizes
and you want larger batch sizes to
improve throughput.
Okay.
So, hopefully that is uh
clear. Any questions about throughput
and latency
and how they're in tension with each
other?
Okay. So, now that we have a conceptual
framework for thinking about how
efficient inference is
in terms of arithmetic intensity
um and
you know, throughput and and latency.
Now, let's try to make it faster. How do
we make inference faster? There's a
bunch of different techniques which are
quite varied ranging from changing the
model architecture to doing systems
optimization and everything in between.
So inference in some sense is a fairly
rich cross-cutting topic.
Okay, so the the most
kind of der
maybe now in hindsight obvious thing you
can think about is hopefully beat it
into your head that um you know memory
is the bottleneck for inference and the
KV cache takes up a lot of memory.
And it could even be larger than the
number of you know parameters if for a
large enough batch size.
So let's just try to reduce the size of
the KV cache.
Now you have to be careful about how you
do this because you want to make sure
you don't lose too much accuracy in the
process.
So here is one thing you can do um which
we already talked about which is grouped
query attention.
Um and just as a kind of a reminder
here. So multi-headed attention
um basically for every token you have a
key and a value and a query. And if you
do grouped query attention
you basically compute um the same number
of queries but you have only
a smaller number of groups and you
compute key and value for each group.
Um okay, so
So K is the a number of of groups here.
Um
and so in the multi-headed attention K
is N no no reduction. Um there's
something called multi-query attention
which no one uses because it's really
bad. K equals 1. And somewhere in
between is hopefully where we'll find a
balance between accuracy and speed.
So there's a this is a paper that
introduces GQA from 2023.
And they show that if you look at you
know time
per sample,
which is related to both latency and
throughput,
um
you know, you see that um
the the MHA, so multi-headed attention,
full attention is has this high
time. Whereas,
if you start K equals 1, it's it's much
faster. And then, you can actually keep
on increasing K to like, you know, K
equals 8 and it's still pretty good. And
eventually,
your
your time goes up quite a bit.
Okay, so
um
you know, why does GQA improve the
latency and throughput?
Well, it reduces the KV cache by a
factor of n over
K.
Um
and
you know, and we just as a friendly
reminder, reducing memory usage leads to
speed up because we're memory bound.
Okay.
So, let's revisit our friendly llama
model here.
Remember in the initial configuration,
we're just using K equals n. So, there's
no multi-headed There's multi-headed
attention, no
no reduction in number of key and
values.
Um and so, for this one,
remember the using a batch size of 64,
we get this throughput and latency.
Now, if you do GQA, we're going to put
in, let's say,
a
kind of a sparsity of 1 to 5.
Um that reduces
the
um you know, the memory quite a bit,
which in turn improves the latency and
also improves the throughput.
So, it's not that latency and throughput
are always at odds. If you reduce the
amount of memory, then it improves both.
It's mainly the batch dimension that
allows that is the point of tension.
Okay, so this is this is great.
Um
and let's actually just improve increase
the batch size even more.
And see what happens.
So, before if we had a batch size of
256,
we ran out of memory. But now it fits in
memory
and
we we see that
you know, the latency you know,
suffers a bit because we're increasing
the batch size, but the throughput
um
you know,
goes up proportionally.
Okay.
So, sometimes you kind of play with
these
parameters jointly. Like you can reduce
the KV cache, but that allows you to
increase the batch size and allow make
making other trade-offs.
So, the final thing you have to do
whenever you do some you know, lossy
change is that you make sure the
accuracy doesn't drop. And this paper
shows that for a JQ JQA
um
the you know, the time is is better, but
the
the across a bunch of evals basically it
works well.
So, now with these accuracy evals, I
think you always have to take it with a
grain of salt because this is like a for
predicting a model later the deep seek
paper would just show that it actually
does hurt. So, you know,
I guess take everything
that's not just kind of math with a
grain of salt here.
Okay, so speaking of deep seek,
here's another idea to reduce the KV
cache.
Okay, so the theme is reduce the KV
cache and latency and throughput
improve.
Um so, this is multi-headed attention,
same number of queries and keys and
values for every
token.
And, GQA, remember, we have reduced the
number of keys and values for every
token.
Um, sorry, not for every token. We
basically basically have reduced the
number of values and
keys.
And now, the multi-latent attention for
DeepSeek
says, we're actually going to leave the
number of keys and values
the the same, one for every, you know,
token essentially, but I'm going to
parameterize I'm going to compress
these.
So, normally, you have some um, how do
you compute your keys and values? You
have your
your activations and you multiply them
by some matrix to get K and some other
matrix to get V. And these are generally
N * H, you know, dimensions, like your
model dim,
which is which is big.
So, MLA says,
I'm going to actually project this these
activations down into C dimensions. So,
DeepSeek V2 reduced it from, you know,
16,000 to 512. So, this is quite
aggressive compression here.
And then, I'm going to compute the K and
the V from this compressed
representation.
So, now I can just store C. This is much
smaller. And then, when I need my keys
and values, I can just materialize them.
So, there is one wrinkle here, which is
that MLA is not compatible with rope,
which operates directly on the keys and
values.
So, what they do is add additional
dimensions
for, you know, for for handling the
rope.
Um,
but more or less, it's it's still
pretty big, you know, reduction.
So, the latency and throughput
improvements
follow by just, you know, simple math.
The smaller the KV cache, the
you know, the faster you go.
Okay, it's almost kind of a
linear scaling up until some point.
And then, remember you need to check
whether your model is, um, you know,
accurate.
So,
um, first of all, this is sort of the
result that, you know, kind of
contradicts the
or or is in tension with, uh, the GQA
paper.
Um, they show that GQA actually isn't
that, um, you know, great. Um,
it
you know, it's, um,
you know, it's much So, this is MHA,
this is GQA. These numbers are smaller
than these numbers.
Um, but, uh, they show that their
method, MLA, multi-layered attention,
uh, works,
um, even a little bit better than MHA.
But, let's just say it's about the about
the the same. So, this column and this
column are much better than I guess
there's no GQA on this table. It's, uh,
yeah, compare over here.
Okay. So,
I'll show you an Yeah. Question.
>> How does this compare,
uh, to reducing the number of dimensions
of the model?
>> So, the question is, how does this
compare with reducing the dimension of
the model?
Um, so that's a good question. I don't
These ablations don't show that. Um, my
guess is that reducing the model
dimension just makes things, you know,
worse if you should because you're sort
of like indiscriminately just like
reducing everything.
Um, I think the
the trick in all of this kind of is to
find places in the model where you can
squeeze.
Um, and this
a priori, I don't think you can
necessarily know for sure. You just have
to do a bunch of experimentation to see
what works.
So, here's another idea to reduce your,
uh, KV cache. This is called cross-layer
attention.
Um, so the idea is that normally every
layer has KV uh K's and V's.
But
we don't let's say instead of doing
that, we're just going to compute um KVs
for a subset of the layers and then just
for the this this layer I'm just going
to use the previous layers um KV cache.
Okay?
So um
So this is kind of another way of
sharing just like GQA shares KV's across
heads.
Now I'm sharing KVs across layers.
Um and empirically this paper shows that
um
you know doing this improves the Pareto
you know frontier. So
um
each of these these models is better
than
um
you know in given a method you can
always
uh kind of sweep this the size of the KV
uh cache by changing the the K and um
the head dimension. Um which it's I
guess kind of relates to your point
about changing model dimension. Um and
then but if you do this uh
CLA cross-layer attention, it's uh it's
better.
Okay. So let me give you uh moving on um
world wind tour of different techniques
for reducing KV cache. There's uh local
or sliding window attention. This is
fairly kind of old uh idea and a very
uh kind of natural idea. So
um if you look at the full attention
matrix is n squared.
And instead of doing that, if you're
going to generate a token, you just look
at the last K tokens.
Okay? So you essentially have a sliding
window for every token you generate, you
just depend on the last um K.
Um
And now if you do that, the
the effective
uh so the KV cache is now independent of
the sequence length. It's just, you
know, um
the number of uh
um the batch times the the other
variables.
Um which is great and this is especially
great for long context.
Um
Now,
you because of number of layers, the
effective context length has actually
larger than the number of the stated
context length because information can
propagate um
you know, farther and if you go down the
layers.
Um now you can do fancier things like
you can maybe not do a dense uh
selection of layers, but you can space
it out. You can also do this global plus
sliding window where you [snorts] have
attention to a fixed um you know, grid
of different, you know, uh token points
plus a local uh sliding window. So you
can do various things.
Now, the problem with this is that it
actually still hurts accuracy.
So this reduces expressivity. There's
no, you know, free lunch here.
Um
or at least this was an expensive lunch.
So the solution that people come up with
is that they interleave local attention
with uh global attention. So these
hybrid uh models have uh you know, full
attention for some of the layers and
some local layers for, you know, some of
the other layers.
And you basically always trying to and
then so that allows you to essentially
um
you know, reduce the the KV cache a
little bit and you're always trying to
balance uh you know, accuracy with
speed.
Yeah.
>> How do all of these
or the difference in the trade-off
between like a linear attention variant
versus like a sliding window?
>> Yeah, so question is what about um
linear attention versus sliding window
attention. So
um I'm not going to talk about linear
attention, but maybe very quickly.
Um, there's a bunch of
um, methods that where instead of
you know, storing a KV cache, this you
basically
um,
compute some sort of like compressed
representation of all the history. So,
linear the most naive linear attention
is uh, you just sum the KV uh, values up
into a single vector. So, that's
definitely independent of the sequence
length. You can do fancier things.
There's like GateNet, DeltaNet, and
Mamba, which allows you to um, try to
compress, but not forget, you know, as
much. Um, now the question is, you know,
how do those compare? Those have also
been used in in place of sliding window
um, attention.
Um, and people have gotten good results
with them. You can also use a
combination of full attention, sliding
window attention, and the linear
attention, because they sort of capture
different, you know, aspects. If you
care about kind of local kind of
high-resolution stuff, then sliding
window attention's better. If you just
kind of want like broad summaries of the
past, then um,
the other, you know, the linear
attention might be better.
>> So, then for like a long context, then
is what you say when your attention
would be a better
setting for that?
>> Um, so the question is for long context,
would linear attention be um, better?
Um, let me talk a
um,
so there's no free lunch, right? Like
like I think let's say you have a very
long context, and you're sort of solving
a needle in a haystack problem, right?
If you have
have to compress your entire history
into like a small context, you're just
going to lose information, and um, you
might just
you know, not be able to retrieve it.
>> I guess my I guess I feel like
what it seems like people are going with
hierarchies, that but always need some
sort of longer attention, but I'm not
I'm just trying to understand like in my
head like what the trade-off between
using a sliding window versus like some
sort of Mamba DeltaNet layer would be.
And like is using a DeltaNet layer like
better than using sliding window
consistently or like what is the actual
like maybe representative trade-offs?
>> Yeah, I I guess maybe I'll say that the
Mamba and DeltaNet are more powerful
um than the sliding window attention.
Maybe you can think about the Mambas
um probably can
like it certainly can represent some of
the aspects of sliding window attention
because like you can just as you're
doing the recurrence it can just look at
the last you know state so
um
maybe
yeah maybe you can say think about the
the linear attention or it's like
extensions as being you know you know
better. At least they're they have more
room. Like it's once you do sliding
window attention like you're done
there's nothing else you can
Okay, so let me just quickly go through
this
just highlight this
you know DeepSeek. DeepSeek continues to
you know innovate different types of
attention mechanisms.
So remember they came up with the
multi-latent attention which compresses
the key values.
There is this thing called
now they have compressed sparse
attention DeepSeek sparse attention and
heavily compressed attention. I never
kind of remember
all these acronyms and what they
they mean but let's look at this
diagram. So normally you have your
KV tokens
and your your query token. So
compressed attention is going to
basically compress every M tokens into
you know one token.
And then there's this thing called
DeepSeek sparse attention
which
basically selects a subset of those to
kind of
keep And the way you select a subset is
that you actually compute some light
lighter weight queries and keys and then
you do it like a, you know, a small
attention to get these index scores so
you know what to keep. So like a kind of
a lightning fast way to figure out what
tokens you need to keep and then you use
those. Um and then there's a more
compression that, you know, happens.
Um so
in the interest of time I'll move on.
Um
The goal of this section is to reduce
the KV cache um because KV cache is
related to memory and we re saw that uh
inference is memory bound. So
um
that directly translates to improvements
in throughput and uh latency.
And the key is to do this without
hurting accuracy. So you can do lower
dimensional KV uh caches across layers
um by across uh heads um and across
like, you know, head dimension.
You can do local attention. You can do
linear attention, which was discussed
earlier. Um
And there's much more. Uh and also
there's also diffusion models, which um
is a non-autoregressive way to generate,
which can be much um faster.
Okay.
So let's talk about a few other ideas,
which are important. So quantization is
more of a I would say less of a
architecture and much more of a systems
uh
perspective on how to make things, you
know, smaller. So um the key idea here
is just reduce the precision of numbers.
Less memory means higher latency and
throughput. Um and the obviously you
have to worry about accuracy.
So
quantization um
um is
um you know, there's many options here
all the way from BF16 all the way down
to int um int four.
Um And so one thing you can do, um, if
you're kind of scared that quantization
is going to mess you up is that you
train a model with quantization in mind.
So, this is called quantization aware
training. Um, and during the feedforward
pass during training, you quantize and
dequantize, and you're basically
simulating these quantization errors as
you train.
Um, so then you're generally now the
weights are adapted towards the
quantization, things will work better,
but the con is that requires
expensive uh large-scale training. And
typically what So, what typically people
do is they they train models and then
they um quantize after the fact.
So, this is post-training quantization.
It's much uh you know, cheaper often.
Um,
you know, there's a naive way to do it
is that you basically uh for every layer
or tensor, you basically determine the
scale and the zero point for each, let's
say, tensor, and then you you quantize
um that you know, separately. Um, this
is generally, you know, doesn't work as
well. Um, you can use um
this idea called GPTQ, which uses some
Hessian information to, you know,
quantize layer by layer, and then the
you keep track of the errors which get
um
propagated into the non-quantized
weights, and so it kind of allows you to
correct for the errors.
And now activation aware quantization is
um um
you know, more so kind of a
sophisticated um way, where the
observation is that some activation
channels are large, and those the
weights that interact with those matter
more. So, let's allocate more precision
to these weights. So, let's look at this
picture. Um, so normally, if you take uh
FE16 um weight matrix and you quantize
it, you get let's say you quantize it
down to N3.
But,
um what you're going to do is you figure
out which of these, um
you know, active So, these are maybe
activation channels, and some of these
activation channels are large. So, as if
they're large in general, then you
basically allocate like let's say FP16
for this channel.
You keep everything else as N3, and for
a few important channels, you um you uh
use higher precision.
Okay.
So, another idea here is to do model
pruning.
So, here you just take a large model,
and you rip out pieces of it, and you
fix it up. It's kind of um a very crude
way, but it uh turns out to work. So,
there's this paper from
um Nvidia, where um
essentially, let me actually
um
uh let's see. So, you kind of have first
have to estimate the importance of the
different parts of the model,
um and you know, choose the most
important parts, and then you basically
remove um different, you know, um hidden
units, and different
um even
uh you know, layers,
um
and now now we have a model. It's not
going to be very good.
Um and so, what you do is you post-train
it. You train it some more on the data
or the task that you care about to kind
of heal it.
Okay? So, this is in some sense a
training
uh purse weighted um to you know, reduce
the KV fit cache, but where you sort of
initialize it with parts of a of a good
model.
Okay. So, this seems to work pretty
well. So, they were able to take a 15B
model, and reduce it to a 8B model,
um
and and it doesn't really hurt accuracy
Uh by too much and the amount that you
use to kind of train the model or
through this process is much less.
Okay, so just to summarize here. Um,
you know, the game is to reduce the
uh, inference complexity without hurting
accuracy. You can think about this is
mostly reducing either number of
parameters or K V cache.
Um, you can define a faster model
architecture, train it, or you can
um,
define a faster model architecture,
initialize
the weights from original model, which
might have a different architecture, but
you kind of just make this Frankenstein
thing, and then you repair the faster
model with um, distillation.
Okay.
Yeah.
>> I'm just saying what about how do you
distinguish the important layers from
the unimportant layers?
>> Um, so how do you distinguish the
important layers from the unimportant
layers? So,
um,
you know, in general you have, you know,
a calibration you know, set and you pass
the the the inputs through the model and
you're basically looking at, you know,
the magnitude of uh, the activations and
the ones that are, you know, some of
them, especially if they're dead units,
will be kind of close to zero and the
ones that are large you want to keep.
So, that's a high-level idea.
>> I guess like why does it matter if the
activations like high? It could just be
like
like what if it's just always high for
Or like is that
>> So, in general okay, so the question is
why what if all the activations are
high? So, in general this is a kind of
empirical observation that
some of the channels will be much higher
than others. If this weren't true, then
these techniques wouldn't necessarily
work.
Um, but it happens to be true, because
um,
you know, that's how these models ended
up being, you know, trained. Um, and
then you can exploit that.
>> Well, I I just made up like this like
say a neuron which is always like value
100 for a prompt like across all the
samples.
>> Yeah.
>> Would that mean that it's
necessarily meaningful or like maybe
it's just an artifact of training that
I'm just
like
going into
>> Yeah, I see. So, the the question is
what if a neuron is always 100? Um, I
mean, if that's the case, you can look
you can also look at kind of variance
um, related questions.
Like if it's 100, you can't just like
remove it, because then everything's
going to be broken, but you can if it's
high mean and low variance, maybe
there's another, you know, a way to just
incorporate the bias, essentially.
Okay, let me quickly go through this
other idea. So, so far we've looked at
lossy methods, which basically
kind of really crunch down the KV cache,
but it could hurt accuracy. There's a
very elegant way of doing this in a
lossless way. This is called speculative
sampling or speculative decoding.
So, um, remember that if you're doing
prefill, you can code all the tokens in
parallel, and this also gives you
probabilities. This is fast, this is
compute-bound, and all nice things. And
in generation, it's one at a time.
Okay, so checking is faster than
generation. If I give you a sequence,
it's fast to tell me how good it is,
much faster than it is to generate one
at a time.
Okay, so you can exploit this asymmetry
using the following idea.
So, what we're going to do is use a a
cheap draft model to basically generate
from. You guess a few tokens, let's say
four tokens, and then we're going to use
the model we actually care about, the
target model Q,
which to basically review these tokens
and accept or not accept them.
Okay? So, so things are kind of choosing
to be balanced. The draft model is a
smaller and cheaper, and so even though
it's memory bound and it has to generate
one at a time, it's not too bad.
Whereas, the target model is big and
expensive, but what we're doing is
asking it to process a batch of tokens
in parallel, so it won't also be too
bad.
Okay, so here's the
the video that shows kind of how
things work. So, if you use a big model
token by token, that's it's going to be
pretty slow. But, if you are
doing speculative decoding,
then
um
then you can see the small model I kind
of generating a bunch of tokens,
um and then the large model uh
basically uh
you know
critiquing them, and then so you
basically can you get this sort of burst
of tokens, and then maybe another burst
of tokens, and so on and so forth.
Okay. So, um here is the the algorithm
for There's a few papers that came out
with uh speculative decoding around the
the same time. This is, you know, one of
them. Um
And so, the idea here is that
um in order to generate, we're going to
generate K tokens,
um and we're just going to sample from
this draft model. So, Q is a draft uh
sorry, P is a draft model. We're going
to sample K tokens,
and then in parallel, we're going to um
compute the logits of these draft tokens
using Q.
And then now, we have to determine
whether we accept or not, and this is
where you do do do a bit of math and,
you know, probability and statistics.
You basically are going to accept with
probability min one over this ratio of Q
over P.
So, if
Q is
um
you know much larger than P, the larger
the Q is, the more likely we want to
accept it.
Um
Uh and and otherwise
um you kind of sample from this you know
residual distribution and exit.
Okay? So, this is basically rejection
you know sampling um except for
rejection sampling sometimes you you you
just when you reject you get nothing,
but if here we always
uh are guaranteed to get an exact sample
from the target model.
Um I'm going to skip this um
you know
kind of simple proof. Um
you can it's basically the same
arguments as kind of rejection sampling
to show that it's the exact uh
um you know probabilities from the
target model.
Um and the initial paper shows that this
is um this fast. And generally, if you
look at there's a you know if you have
too few draft tokens, you're not really
leveraging um the batching on the the
target model side. And if you have too
many, then you're going to reject more
often. So, there's a sweet spot around
you know in this case three or four.
Okay. And in general, the draft model is
much smaller than the target model. And
ideally, you want the model draft model
to be as close to a target, which means
that um you want to kind of distill it.
So, which means that actually a lot of
the same ideas that we just talked about
are applicable to speculative decoding
as well.
So,
basically the the idea is that let's try
to reduce your KV cache um via all the
different shenanigans. And if you end up
with a model you're happy with, just
serve that. If you're not happy with it,
then it at least can be a draft model,
and you can use your main model to fix
things up.
Um there's a bunch of um whole
literature on speculative decoding um
right now that improve over the um
original um which I'll kind of skip for
now.
Okay, so very quickly now um
dynamic workloads. Okay, so this is the
use case is your you're serving a live
website and come users come and chat
with your model. Um the requests arrive
at different times.
Um
they have different shared prefixes and
they have different lengths.
Um so it's kind of pretty messy.
It's far from this kind of very simple
training where you have these blocks of
um you know uh the same number of tokens
all at once.
So what do you do in this case? So
there's this um
um idea this is system called Orca that
was built. This is actually very early
on which uh introduces idea of
continuous uh batching.
So the idea is that
um
you get a bunch of requests that look
like this. So uh here's a prefix of the
first request and you're generating this
token. Here's the second one. Um here's
the third one and fourth one. It's
jagged because every prefix has a
different length. And what we're going
to do is we're going to decode step by
step.
So every step you decode one token for
all the sequences. Next step you decode
another token for all the sequences. And
then if you end you just you know eject
that um sequence.
And then as new requests arrive to the
batch then you basically put it in the
batch and um then you just kind of
continue.
Um so that's why it's called continuous
batching because it's sort of this your
batch is dynamically um being updated um
with either old finished uh sequences
being evicted and new ones coming in.
So now one problem here is that
um
you know,
everything we've seen batching works
when all the sequences have the same
dimensionality, right? You have tensors,
everything every every slice has the
same dimensionality.
But, in it if each if request here has a
different length, so what do you do
about that?
So, there's this idea called selective
batching where
um you let's say you have, you know, a
three length three, length nine, and
length five.
So, here um in the attention
computation, you can't really do
anything about this because attention
sort of depends on the the length of
your your sequence. So, if you have a
3x3
you know, a computation and 9x9
computation, you can't really um you
know, share the the tensor effectively.
But, for the non-attention, the MLP
layers, which is, you know,
takes up a lot of, you know, flops, you
can actually just concatenate all the
sequences together to form a mega
sequence and you process that.
Okay. So, final idea is page attention.
This was introduced in the VLM paper.
Um of course, VLM has many other bells
and whistles now, but this is kind of
the core idea at that time.
So, um
so, the question is how is
the KV cache stored?
Right? So, if you think about um
requests coming in,
the you have to put them in memory
somewhere. And in general, there's this
problem that you get fragmentation. This
is what happens to
or used to happen to your your your hard
drive. Um and you have to defrag your
hard drive um you know, back in the day.
Um so,
so, there's two types of fragmentation.
One is that you have to allocate enough
buffer
um so that because you don't know a
priori when you're going to stop. So,
you might have a max token limit of
like, you know, 1024. So, you have to
allocate all this memory, and you can't
put anything in there because you don't
you're going to just generate until
you hit the max tokens, and that's very
wasteful. That's internal fragmentation.
And then, there's also you have there
could be space between different
requests, and that space is maybe too
small to get used effectively, so that's
just wasted space.
So, the solution here is just, you know,
these are systems people so they know
their operating systems. They said,
"Okay, well, we solved this problem once
before, so let's just use the same idea
here."
So, we're going to divide the KV cache
of a sequence into
non-contiguous
you know, blocks. Okay, so if you have
this sequence, "Four score and seven
years ago our fathers brought forth."
We're just going to chunk it up into
these blocks of size four.
Doesn't matter where the blocks go, but
they're going to be kind of aligned
according to the blocks. So, there's
some uniformity there.
So, when two requests share the same
can actually share the same KV cache.
Um
so
um
So, you might have this block and and
this block. So, this block might go here
and here, and this block might be over
there. So, they're they're in kind of
interspersed, but as long as you have
the indices and keep track of where
everything is, that's fine.
Um
so
in particular, if you have um you know,
system prompts
then you can actually just, you know,
cache these system prompts
um the KV cache in the system prompts
once. Right? And that can be useful for
all the queries.
Okay, so this is very useful because if
a lot of people are using the same
system prompt, then you don't have to
compute the KV cache for every
you know, request.
Also, there are many applications where
you have the same
prompt and you actually want to generate
multiple responses. So in that case,
you can also just share the KV cache for
all the
for the prompt and just have unique
responses coming out.
Okay, so
So for example, if you were to generate
let's say multiple
generations from fourscore and seven
years ago are blank. And so
what would happen here is that you would
have fourscore and seven and you would
start by having years ago or our.
And then um
this is called
copy on write semantics. You keep this
and then we have these two samples and
if they had happened to sample the let's
say the same token, you just you know,
just continue with that. But if they
sample different tokens, you split the
block. And then you can kind of continue
there. So you're basically sharing as
much of the prefix cache as you as you
can.
Um there's a bunch of other
optimizations like you know, kernels
that I'm not going to have time to go
over.
Um but the general idea is that
you're using kind of these operating you
know, systems and metaphors to manage um
kind of your inference.
Okay, so summary here. Inference is
really really important.
Um
it's very different from training even
though it's the same model, but you're
asking the model to do something very
different. Ends up being very memory
bound and um it's also you know, dynamic
if you're kind of in a live chatbot use
case.
We saw a variety of different techniques
um to improve inference. You can
quantize, you can come up with new
architectures, you can prune and
distill. You can also use speculative um
you know, sampling. But all of these are
driven by the same you know, principle
here, which is reduce your KV cache, but
don't hurt accuracy too much.
Um and then there's ideas from, you
know, you know,
systems um like paging and speculative
execution that can be brought to bear
for actually
live kind of inference servers.
Um one thing we didn't really get a
chance to talk about, which was
discussed briefly, is that I think that
new architectures have actually a huge
potential for, you know, improvement.
Things like, you know, state space
models or linear attention or diffusion.
Um these can you know, at some level,
the KV cache and the way that attention
is is built fundamentally makes
it an inference-unfriendly archi- uh
kind of architecture. So, if you can
come up with a new architecture that is
sort of designed for inference in the
way that the transformer was not, this
can maybe unlock a lot.
Okay, so I will uh stop there. And next
class uh Tats will return and talk about
uh scaling laws part two.